given that the National Geographic
Channel film takes some different view
from you none of this information in the
film will will change the focus of your
obsession or how you see Stonehenge in
its place in history and they can say
what they like and it's very impressive
I've seen it it's very impressive it
looks great but it's there's something
missing
there's something missing and the
original Stonehenge was wood and it in
it and by a process of rain and peat and
saliva turns into rock see you can say
saliva where's that come from hello
dinosaurs do you think they didn't drool
you think a t-rex just had its mouth
shut the whole time no they were true in
all over the place it's the first thing
you learn in school drool peat rain
stone yeah so I don't say UFO please
don't say yes no no I had no no
intention of saying you just said it
that I yes you're right I did see aliens
had nothing to do with Stonehenge at all
it's ridiculous they built the pyramids
for sure yeah but they did had nothing
to do with Stonehenge we'll Dave real
made one pass over their souls burying
they went Oh No thank you
right hmm not in that language because
they speak a different language but they
said I don't think so it's a little
chilly
pyramids take me to Egypt nice and warm